I'll declare this ordinary meaning of
sorry extraordinary meaning of counsel
open at 4:30 today we have an apology
from councillor grant cancelled a grant
an apology for lateness from councillor
Phillips somebody like to move those
apologies be sustained please
Thank You Stuart and Signet Bronwyn
thank you
those in favor please say aye thanks the
motion is carried
thank you okay so on the agenda this
afternoon and that is amendments that
are required to the borrowing documents
for the local government funding agency
and we've got those already circulated
but Steve do you want to talk us through
that you worship thanks this is Canada
particularly awkward time I think for
councils or many councils given that the
council which has to be by resolution
was sought and signatures obtained by 30
April however at the agreements and is a
whole suite of these agreements and they
run up 250 pages long to each one and
they had been prepared by Russell
McVeigh a very long-standing prestigious
law firm on behalf of the local
government funding agency in turn the
documents have been critiqued on behalf
of shareholding councils by Simpson
Grayson and I wonder what they call the
big four law firms
so as a result of that we have now being
invited to along with all other councils
who participated in the local government
funding agency fees via the foreign
facility it has to formally approve
these documents ostensibly the main
changes are around allowing CCO to
participate in the
the ability to secure funds from the
agency now now this council doesn't have
any CCO CEOs for new counselors as a
sort of term for council controlled
organizations but a number of
particularly large accounts have quite a
few council controlled organizations
which are which are big entities in
their own right they are individual
legal entities but they are just happen
to be hunted or not always had a resume
but a majority shareholding of a parent
Council
so these documents have been amended to
reflect that and here's some change to
the borrowing notes which you're an
effector fee you pay when you draw down
funds I guess my take on this your
worship is that it's probably testimony
to the success of the local government
funding agency we see that by the last
government and has proved to be
enormously successful in terms of giving
giving local government the opportunity
to secure funds a very competitive rate
than what would normally be the case
before on the open market with trading
begs to the point now that pretty much
in its face of a couple years you know
borrowings have looked on the head and
so the vast majority is held by the
local government funding agency and just
a small percentage but swaps with
training hmm thanks Steve okay so open
for discussion in questionings
any questions from councils that you'd
like to raise at this point in time no
so I think it looks reasonably
straightforward and so if there is no
question but something like to move the
recommendation that we have this 19 3 3
for Pat recommendation would somebody
like to move that as this move to
councillor hasty and Singh did council
MacPhail is there any further discussion
there's not put that motion although
simple
press our against the motion is carried
Thank You counselors as I said there was
only one item of substance on the agenda
we've just completed that so that brings
us to the close of this meeting that
probably would have to be some sort of
record I think in terms of all council
meetings not just a zoom:1
with school district so so thank you for
your participation and I declare the
meeting closed thank you just before you